ريبيت
ليله راس السنه كانت مختلفه بالنسبه لهذه
الاسره الاوكرانيه
الحرب فرقت اوليه عن زوجته واطفاله فقط تم
استدعائه للخدمه العسكريه مارس الماضي
مكالمه هاتفيه ينتظرها الاطفال بفارغ
الصبر
احيانا لا نتمكن من رؤيته
لكن اللقاء وان نذر يكون دائما مميزا
الينا التقت بزوجها اولي اخر مره في
اكتوبر خلال جنازه زوج شقيقته الذي تطوع
عده مرات للقتال قبل ان يلتحق بوحده
الدفاع الجوي
ولم ينجو لكنه لم يمت على الفور تم ارساله
الى كريماتوس وتوفي في الطريق فقد حياته
حتى نتمكن من الاحتفال بالسنه الجديده
ونستمر بالعيش في عام 2023
وانا بمراتي لكن الوحده قد تكون قاسيه
احيانا
تحاولوا علينا واطفالها التمسك بامل عوده
زوجها سالما بالرغم من ان الحرب قد لا تضع
اوزارها قريبا